[Music]
okay how about this news out of London
has been all about that growing royal
rift between sister-in-law Duchess Kate
and Meghan well Kate was greedy fans in
Leicester and she got asked this
question excited for Megan and tell you
baby yeah alright what do you think I
don't love when people pit women against
other women both of these ladies have a
lot on their plate let's just let them
be and buy the clothes that they wear
all right Royals besides well me Kelly
Ripa she's a new face book series with
Rachel Harris who co-starred with Megan
on Sue's but sadly that royal connection
didn't pay off the way Kelly had hoped
well I had decided that I was going to
be Rachel's plus one at the Royal
Wedding but I guess I guess you had to
work and you couldn't go so hence I
couldn't
[Laughter]
so no royal invite for the besties
who've been known to bust a move on the
dance floor we officially fell in love
at a wedding in Italy we did everything
together that weekend and I was like oh
I've never met another person willing to
do a split on the dance floor in a gown
before are you my person
Kelly's based in New York while Rachel
bounces between Toronto and LA shooting
her show suits and Lucifer and the now
BFFs have turned their nofilter FaceTime
convos into a new Facebook watch show
called heads and faces we could use
simmers for the paper yeah you could
have you ever wiped with the cardboard
yes we decided that nothing was
off-limits
there was no topic that was too taboo
one hot topic during their bicoastal
chats Callie's hot husband Mark
Consuelos
like every date he's like is this okay
is this
okay can I touch you here can I touch
you there because he's never sure what's
glued in and what's clipped in oh yeah
actually a part of my body
[Music]
[Applause]